you recently said that you would love to
revisit lizzie mcguire it's been over 15
years since the movie came out have
there been any conversations yes yeah
maybe I don't want to spend all my time
hanging out with cool kids and hot tubs
[Music]
what's happening is that ago yeah no no
it's definitely not a guy I want to like
get everyone okay while talking about it
but um yeah I mean I love her so much
and I think that she was so important to
girls at an important time in their life
and if she could be important to them
again at this age like I think that
would be amazing
where do you think Lizzie would be these
days there's been lots of conversations
about that so I don't know I'm wracking
my brain I don't I don't think she's a
mom yet but she might be getting there
soon yeah it's fun I feel I feel excited
and you know I don't really know that it
could be a possibility or it could be
nothing so we'll see Hilary Duff
confirming to et that talks about a
Lizzie McGuire revival are the hit show
ran from 2001 to 2004 on the Disney
Channel
since when does Ethan Kraft turn into
jelly around me everyone's acting all
different ever since I became a
celebrity for now the 31 year old is
focused on younger season six starts
filming in February and raising her two
kids Luka and six week old daughter
thanks
so how is life balancing two kids oh my
gosh honestly I feel like I can't
complain about it because people have
more than two kids and I'm sitting here
like how do people do this oh my gosh
spike by 5 p.m. at night when Luka is
like great you know it's like school
pick up and then he usually has an
after-school activity and I'm like
nursing the baby after school activity
and then we're like running home and
it's like homework and dinner and bath
time and trying to be fun and you know
continue like our whole regimen and
I just have a baby on my boob the whole
entire time so it's pretty insane and an
amazing at the same time you just do it
you know you just figure out a way to do
it but I don't know if we call it
balance yet
ya know maybe in a couple years right
mayhem yeah Luka adjusting to being a
big brother he's amazing and honestly
it's just kind of like she's always been
there like he when I start to feel bad
that you know obviously a newborn needs
their mom the most and when I start to
feel bad that she consumes most of my
time I look at him and he's like totally
fine and he is so loving towards her and
it's always like crowded like holding
her face and I wants to hold her and
then you know when she starts to cry
he's like mom she's gonna blow get her
weight though you thought it's really
sweet honestly it's like she's always
been there and he's just like whoa
[Music]